my name is uh i'm jim assad um
i worked with facebook and i'm here to
talk to you about uh javascript
debugging uh so actually when um i first
started working at facebook about
um seven or eight months ago
one of the main things that i focused on
is just quality so i worked on the photo
steam
and
one of the things that we needed to
optimize and make better was the
album upload quality and um
and so we didn't build new products i
didn't like ship a ton of code i just
spent a lot of my times just debugging
javascript and we came up with this
number that is about upload reliability
just to tell us
how well we're doing it's all like our
main metric that we wanted to hit
um
and you know when people uh hear
reliability a lot of the times they they
they think about like the four nines of
reliability and think about like servers
and things like that but uh
one thing that is a lot of time is
missing is actually a reliability from
the client side
and
because of that i spend a lot of my time
just debugging javascript
and debugging javascript at facebook is
not like debugging javascript at any
other smaller product because you have a
lot of javascript uh on the page you
have
thousands and thousands of javascript
modules and they load lazily and they uh
so it's just like ever increasing
javascript uh so i ended up learning a
lot of techniques uh that are
as i'd like to say lesser known
techniques in uh in debugging javascript
and um this is what i'm i'm gonna talk
about today so actually
uh we got 1
increase in upload reliability
on facebook.com
by fixing a few javascript bugs
so you don't usually hear that when
people talk about reliability they talk
about like how they like create
distributed servers or whatever they're
talking about but we actually got one
percent increase from
um
from purely javascript device
uh
when i sat down to prepare for this talk
a few months ago i thought it'd be
interesting to start with a question so
how far have we come how far have we
come in terms of javascript development
how far have we come in terms of the
tools that we have today
and that took me back to 2001.
in 2001 i was in high school but i also
did
visual basic programming
i really enjoyed
one part of visual basic a lot which is
the interactive nature of of of
programming i know a lot of you may
thinking like vidualistic what the hell
are you talking about but
uh but
you know as someone who was self-taught
what i
used to do is write as little code as
possible just to be able to see
something on the screen and then
instantly jump into the debugger and try
to sort of beat it into shape
so one of the tools that really helped
me do that was called immediate
um
they call immediate i have no reason
i don't think they have any reason why
not to call the console but they call it
immediate it's basically a console or a
rebel
what you can do is you can query the
live environment so you can look at your
variables just to see like what
what the values of your variables are
but what you can also do is call methods
and i think you can also restart the
current call stack
and a lot of the times what i end up
doing is write some code then jump into
debugging and then start changing
variables start calling methods just to
figure out what's wrong and how i can
fix it
um so i really like vbd uh programming
but uh when the web started becoming
ubiquitous uh at least uh where i'm from
i'm from jordan it took us a while until
we
until the web really became a thing i
think in 2001 everyone had a browser uh
i think my friends had browsers even my
grandmother had a browser and uh like
any young nerd i would uh or even like
anyone just hacking on stuff every time
i see a computer that is available at uh
in people's hands i want to just you
know create stuff and
be able to ship it to them right so i
learned a little bit of javascript so
what i learned is how to open a script
tag and how to do document.write because
that was the way to to do javascript
then
um and and i did that i write i wrote
document.write hello world
but then i i opened that in the browser
and what i got was basically just an
empty screen
uh and
i was like oh i must have done something
incredibly horrible that it's treating
me that way i went back to the codes i i
it looked fine and then
went back here until i finally noticed
this small triangle right here
if you really really squint your eyes
and try to look at it
it looks like it's trying to tell you
that there's an error or something
happening on the page
so
i clicked that triangle
and actually
you know sure enough it was trying to
tell me
that there was an error on the page well
at least it's giving me the line number
two
but it's also a very cryptic error
object expected of course you're
expecting objects what do you want from
me
so all this to say that we've really
come
a long way
since uh since that small little silly
triangle to the state of the arts dev
tools that we have today
but this talk is not going to be about
death tools this talk is just going to
be about techniques that i've learned
from javascript
debugging
so i've already talked about this part
uh
i do a bunch of other projects and
sometimes right so you can find me on my
website amazon.me or twitter amazon
so
the talk is going to be three parts
code that's easier to debug debugging
tips and tricks and the tools
so
writing code that's easier to debug
i think the the first thing uh
when i
uh so so you know after 2001 after like
seeing what happened to javascript i
really swore it off and went back to vb
and then just came back to actually web
development in 2009
um and one thing that i found really fun
about web development and javascript in
particular was functions like functions
were really a primary thing and uh you
know having
uh higher level functions and the
ability to to do callbacks and and do
sort of functional programming was
really a fun thing when you're
programming javascript uh but the more
and more i i write production code uh it
becomes more obvious that just writing
everything in lambdas uh is a really
huge pain in the ass when you when you
really want to debug it
so to illustrate that i'm going to give
a few contrived examples so this is a
sort of a warning for the faint-hearted
out there
so
one thing that a lot of times is
emphasized in programming languages is
whether
the state is hidden well or not
i think that's definitely a good
attribute of especially a secure
programming model but a lot of the times
when you're debugging you really need to
have your state exposed in order to
watch it in order to change it in order
to do different stuff on it while you're
debugging so
for example if uh you want to write a
sort of a
counter module uh the way to do it in in
functions is you would have a factory
function called counter you'd pass it a
value and then it will return a function
one called will increment the value and
then it will return the value right
that's a one simple way to do it
if you do it using classes
it's basically a class called counter uh
you instantiate it using new and you
pass it a value it will have a state
which is this dot value
uh and then whenever you can call an um
an increment method on it and that will
increment and and return it so
functionality wise they're they're
equivalent
uh
but the difference is when you're
debugging from the outside say you have
that contour object
if you have the first type of object you
can't really know what's happening
inside it right if you have the second
type of object you can actually just do
counter.value from your console and you
can see what's happening you can also
change that that value while you're
debugging i'll talk a little bit more
about why i think it's valuable to sort
of change things from the console
so another problem with uh with just
using uh functions as the basic unit of
abstraction is that you can't really
monkey patch clojures and i think it's
definitely important
um in production not to do these sort of
stuff to like monkey patch and change
things at runtime but i think while
you're debugging i think it's it's
definitely important to be able to to
change your your classes and your
methods uh to
to do interesting stuff with debugging
so sometimes
sometimes i actually change a method
while debugging just to see what happens
just to see just to try out a new idea
without going back to code and iterate
really fast on it
so here i'm changing increments to
actually decrement it's probably that's
what i'm saying is contrived examples
but it's extremely contrast
um so
here's the like
the extreme example of like using
functions so uh this is actually a way
to implement counter using pure
functions uh let's say you you still
have a factory function
called counter you pass it a value it
returns a function that when called will
expose that original value
and then you have an increment function
that is passed the original function
returned from from the previous function
and we'll return a function once called
will increment that value
um we'll call the original function to
to expose the value and then increment
it um so it's kind of cool to be able to
do these sort of things and like that's
why we love javascript but actually in
production if i i i wanted to debug this
if i wanted to
point to the point where my value
changes and say hey set a breakpoint
where when this value change i can never
do that because guess what the value
never changes
so
another tip is
making classes and objects accessible
from the console
i think this is this is really important
a lot of times we're using require.js
we're using amd we're using all these
really nice tools uh
and they they hide all these modules uh
from you in production that's sort of a
good thing uh actually i would argue
even in production you need to expose
your top level modules uh and definitely
you need to do it in development to be
able to do things from the console i'll
give you a few examples how
this is valuable
so like i said like looking at a object
state or an application state and
debugging is extremely valuable so
let's say you um
you refresh the page and it ran some
code and then you want to check whether
the application in the state you'd
expect it to be right you're trying
let's say you're trying to debug some
some bug that's happening uh it's
incredibly easy to just do app dot
counter value just to get the value from
the counter
now if this is hidden behind clojure you
can
you can't really
do that unless you're inside a
breakpoint
a lot of the times
between different
runs of the code like between clicking
something uh it reveals a lot of times
what's wrong with your application by
just merely looking at your application
state
another important thing is to be able to
start things from the console so let's
say you have a user model and that user
model updates every time it changed from
the server say another user on a
different machine change it you send an
event from the server and then that
re-renders right
now every time you want to debug that
you should uh you basically have to log
in using a different machine log in
using a different user and uh try to
invoke a change event so that the other
client will actually re-render but
that's a lot of work why not just have
your user model accessible from the
console so you can emit changes so we're
basically just like emitting and
changing the user model and then the
view would react to that and render its
views you can
you can test your code
so another uh really important uh part
is the ability to
set breakpoints from the console so
the way we usually do breakpoints is you
go to the source code of the of the
of the function or the method that you
want to break on and you set a
breakpoint but uh that's limiting
because first of all you need to know
where the source code is you need to
navigate to it but also we don't have
the source code for native methods
so it's going to be incredibly valuable
to be able to debug
methods just from the console so this is
a command line api function that i'll
talk and explain more about later it's
just called debug um and yeah i'll just
explain later
all right so the second part of the talk
is debugging tips and tricks
so
uh
i'll try to like leave you guys with a
few solid tips that you can actually
take home and and use it tomorrow
or today if you like working with it
so
so one thing that i found really
valuable
is to always have my program in a
runnable state
and what i mean by renewable state is
the ability to actually refresh the
browser and get something on the screen
i find it incredibly motivating when i
when i when i always have my program
like that uh i do a lot of side projects
i like to hack on a lot of things on the
side
one of the biggest killers of my side
projects just having it in a broken
state
if uh
if i know that every time i need to go
back to my side projects and spend like
30 minutes just trying to get it to run
just trying to get to a state where it's
actually running i'm just going to
abandon that project so
and that was also
true for development branches
try to get your code always to be in a
runnable state
try to split up your big changes into
smaller steps i think one of the like
eye-opening parts of my career so far
was learning
like really learning version control and
what it can do to you as a developer and
the ability to
uh
to sort of take small bets and uh
iterate quickly on code um
it just profoundly helps uh i'd like to
think about this as breadth first versus
depth first um you know as engineers we
like these kind of analogies um i think
with depth first is you basically so at
any given point you want to solve a
problem you have always a lot of paths
that you can go down
to so
with a depth-first approach with an
approach where you're like really
stubborn and want to get that feature
out and you you're hacking on uh in a
way that you think it's gonna solve that
problem uh you sort of like keep going
down that path and eventually you may
hit a wall where something you didn't
expect happen or an api did not exist
and then you have to backtrack all the
way and you've lost a lot of time
whereas um if you're if you're
approaching your code by doing just
small changes at a time you can easily
just explore new ways of doing things
without actually uh you know getting to
a place where you're too invested in it
to sort of like backtrack and get to the
original state
so i know it's a little bit too abstract
but i'll clarify in a little bit
so
and and to as a follow-up to that point
uh the ability to just change and break
things
uh is is incredibly valuable so
if
if if you know that
just two two steps back if you know that
there's two commands on your console uh
that can basically get your code to a
runnable uh
runnable version it's really easy to
take bold steps it's really easy to try
to do something uh that have like a that
have a minimal chance of success
um
and that also translates while in
debugging mode if you're in debugging
mode uh the ability to just change
methods on the fly the ability to do
live editing to change your value to
change your state just to try a
different path in your code i think is
uh incredibly
important and one final note on that is
lean on your tools just
you know learn version control learn it
really well
and
with debuggers and things like that just
i think it's
very important to
uh to be able to take these bold steps
and the only way to do it with
confidence is to be able to lean on your
tools
so
one tip that i have for you is what i
like to call setting up traps
so a lot of times when you have a large
team that is working on on the same
application a lot of times when uh you
know in websites that's what we do we
all commit to the same uh source control
where all all of our code are eventually
will run on the same thread so it's it's
it's incredibly incredibly frightening
that everyone will
you know you have thousands of engineers
at the company and everyone's code will
eventually co-mingle
um
and
a lot of times you can't step debug
all the code when you're when you're
trying to debug a certain problem and
let me skip to towards an example uh
because this is getting too abstract so
uh the other day i was trying to debug a
problem on facebook.com where uh you're
scrolling and feed and suddenly
uh you're back to the top
just for no reason and uh it was it was
really hard to debug but
um
the first thing that anyone would try is
to go to the code base and grip for the
ways that you can change the scroll
position so how would you change the
scroll position you can either call
scroll to you can call call scroll by or
you can change the scroll top of the
body or the document elements right so
gripping for this and facebook's uh
web code base brings up 3 000 results
so it's going to take me about a year to
go through all of them and try to figure
out whether this is changing my code
um
so the only way i at least for me maybe
maybe you're smarter than me and you can
figure out a better way uh you probably
are but uh for now let's say setting up
runtime traps is the easiest way to
attack this problem so what do i mean by
rent runtime traps
um so here's a here's an example so
um
with with native methods unlike um
your source unlike your own methods uh
we don't have a source for that right so
we can't set a breakpoint on that um so
what we can do is we can actually
replace
the native method we can replace another
function that's why javascript's cool
that's why it's it's malleable it allows
for this sort of thing so we can
basically for example um let's take an
example let's say you have um a link on
the page that is not working you're
clicking that link and that's not taking
you to to the url of that link uh what
could you
what you think is happening is prevent
default uh
is being called somehow right so what
you can do is you can replace the
prevent default function and
insert a debugger statement so next time
prevent default is called you can
it will break and you simply just go up
one step in the stack and you'll see the
offending code and same thing with
scroll top and scroll by and all that
stuff what i did when i attacked this
bug is basically i replaced all these
functions but with a debugger statement
and eventually when that thing called
them i just went one step in the call
stack and i found that a function that
was uh was trying to scroll the page
so actually a fun story about this
particular example
uh
i was uh
i remember seeing a tweet by dominic
and uh i think he was i think you were
saying like i'm feeling pretty good
about myself i i did exactly this and i
was able to cut catch the the function
and uh
and the fun thing about it is
this actually inspired me to
uh to write a blog post and to release
the tools that i've been working on and
eventually the popularity of that stuff
uh led me to sort of apply to
conferences with this talk uh so if you
have any complaints if you think this
stock sucks just direct them to
dominic any thank yous of course
um
so
another uh another uh trap that you can
set is breaking on custom events so
uh when an event a lot of time like
really something annoying about
javascript development is
uh events although like events and
callbacks and asynchronous stuff
although sometimes it could be fun but
it also is an annoying thing to debug uh
so one thing that i found really
valuable is to make when i want to make
sure an event is probably as properly uh
being emitted is to um
to listen at the event with a function
that simply has a debugger statement and
next time that event
is triggered i can the
you know the debugger would break and i
can look in and make sure all the
parameters that i want are being passed
and be able to properly debug it so
uh that's one way that i find valuable
also
i think you'd uh you'd enjoy this
command line api called monitor events
uh when you call it on an element every
time an event is triggered uh is emitted
on the element on the like a dom node uh
it will actually show it in the in the
console
so uh
another one is breaking in property
access
so a lot of times you have changes uh
that goes um
you know your
your step debugging and suddenly you
find that one of your variables or one
of your states
or one property on your object suddenly
is changing from under your feet and you
didn't know what changed it
unlike methods we can't really replace
it with a function to be able to
uh to debug it but what you can do is
add setters and getters and inside that
setters and getters so are you guys
familiar with the setters and getters
you are all right cool uh and inside the
setter you'll just have a debugger
statement and next time something tries
to set that
that
property on your
on your object um you'll get a break
point and you you'll be able to find out
uh what's trying to change your your
variables another fun thing i think in
the in the blog post that i wrote i
linked to your your vlog about this
you've logged out with this right yeah
this is the one that i've dealt with
yeah
so i'm just getting ideas from everyone
and just you know taking them
um
so uh another thing which is very
similar to uh
to the events part is just on callbacks
just you know adding that debugger
statement on callbacks
uh
and
finally um actually not finally just one
more thing is breaking dom mutations so
this actually can be done from dev tools
you can actually right click and and um
and break on attribute modification or
or subtree modification and this works
uh pretty well
but um i think if if you do it manually
so if you listen to dom mutation events
yourself you can have more fine grained
control over what what uh changes that
you want to do
um
and also uh
a cool thing that landed recently in
chrome devtools was async call stack so
before if you if you tried to do this
you just get a very small call stack
because the dom mutation event uh
was the cause of the uh of your function
to be executed but with async call
stacks you'll actually see what caused
that original uh change to happen and
then you'll get a full call stack
so another one that is uh sort of
speculative so object mutation events um
recently landed using object.observe
and i'm thinking maybe in the future we
can be able to debug on properties like
add change delete but right now with
this with object.observe there isn't uh
async call stack i don't know why but
i'm thinking this is a bug or not
working yet
just release chrome 36 today it might be
in there okay
check that
um
so the final part which is uh tools
this is the part where i tell you about
uh all the fancy tools that you can use
um
so the first one uh command line api so
learn it i'm not gonna spend a lot of
time because i think it's gonna need
like five talks to be able to talk about
devtools and all the features that that
devtools has and i think you guys gotta
talk uh like at this uh meetup like a
uh about devtools at some point um
so but these are my favorites dollar
sign zero uh whatever you have selected
in the elements pane is this is actually
a reference to it
uh dollar sign is query selector all
just alias to dollar sign monitor events
i explained before and then get event
listeners will get you all the event
listeners on a given element
one zero three yeah
um
this is a wrong slide because it's not
undocumented anymore uh so i blogged
about it i boasted about you know
finding undocumented apis
um and uh they finally fixed it um and i
i remember like tweeting at point irish
uh and saying
um hey i guess i'll have to
stop saying it's undocumented apis and
he's like i'm just i'm just trying to
show off here to say that i was the
reason they documented the apis but
uh
but those apis are really really like
profoundly awesome i don't know why
people did not use them before
hard yeah um yeah what was that
the originality of the monitor is one
dior
oh yeah that's fine that's why people
did not
but anyways uh so debug giving any any
uh
reference to a function you just call
debug on it and it will actually set a
breakpoint on the first line in that
function it's awesome just try it next
time you're in devtools monitor will do
the same or we'll just log the
parameters past that function
so debug utils is
a tool that i tried to capture
everything that i told you about now and
a lot more uh that has all these tools
to allow you to set breakpoints and
setters getters events um
uh what else
let's see uh
getters setters events um methods um and
a lot of other things just go to
github.com amazon debug utils
and and yeah yeah i i really i really
recommend it it's it's awesome i know
i'm biased but i think it's still
awesome
but uh so another thing that i've
mentioned earlier in this talk is is
live editing and i think live editing is
an awesome feature
that really
really plays well with what i'm talking
about here is trying to
change your environment trying to change
your code as much as possible to learn
while in the live environment to be able
to iterate fast on your code and then
taking all everything that you've
learned and putting it back into code
so live editing is is a way to actually
change live code so a lot of people say
hot swapping or there's a lot of
different names live coding whatever you
want to call it uh so by
by
but what really why do i really want
live editing you know i can i can talk
about how you know we're artists and we
should not be separated from from the
art that we're creating and all that
but it's really crap what i
what i really want why i really want
live editing for is because i'm lazy
because i'm impatient because i'm a
sloppy coder you know i i do a lot of
typos i want to be able to fix them on
the fly without like doing another
refresh cycle i want to be able to see
my code as soon as possible uh without
losing motivation and going on twitter
or reddit or whatever and because i'm
really lazy i don't want to like keep
all tabbing between things
um
so
so here's a here's a video
uh that illustrates why live coding is
good so of course this is dodge script
this is what we use at facebook
and i'm trying to set a console log on a
function that uploads a photo just part
of the work that i've done
so i go and refresh facebook.com and i
try to go to the user flow where i'm
working on which is the
and then i see this gif and i i get
distracted for an hour in my timeline
and clicked on it and just like look at
this guy that's taking
so many so much ecstasy but um
but then i finally get to my
get to my actual thing just to go back
and see that there's a there's a typo or
or an error uh so this is just to
illustrate
how hard it is to
uh to just iterate and code really fast
it's not only the the time it takes to
refresh but also it's the time to to get
to the user fall but it's also the risk
that you're going to get distracted by
something else along the way or maybe
maybe it's only me but i get distracted
often especially like refreshing
facebook.com and getting all that
timeline
so uh so i i built this tool uh just to
to help me iterate faster and and be
able to write code without having to go
back and forth and refreshing the the
page so i call it uh flow but for
trademark reasons i call it fb flow
and
it's an open source tool by facebook it
allows you live edit javascript css and
actually like any static resource
it supports build steps and any
development environment it's also easy
to integrate and hackable
so
um
at the most basic uh
explanation for it it's it basically
it's a tool that allows you to write
code in your register and immediately
see it in the browser window without
having to refresh even javascript i know
a lot of people use live reload and live
edit and a lot of those stuff but this
is also not just for css but also
javascript
so
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna feel like
uh and genuine if i
uh or this genus i don't know what the
word but i'm not going to feel good
about myself if i didn't mention all the
tools the other tools like live reload
lifestyle are really good for css but
they don't do javascript um another tool
that does javascript is chrome
workspaces which is what flow is built
on top of
the dev tools but chrome workspace is
the prob there are a few problems that i
try to solve with it um it doesn't
support a build step so if you actually
if you're using es6 or dodge script um
you
uh every time
uh
it
chrome workspaces stops working if
you're if you have source maps live edit
stops working and there's no support for
remote file systems you can only map
static resources to your local file
system but not remote file system and
you can't choose your your favorite
editor you have to use chrome devtools
editor
so how is flow built
flow is two components the server side
component and the client component the
server side component is a is an npm
module that you basically require and
then you write a simple function uh i
call resolver which basically just uh tr
um
it's a mapping between uh the static
resource and uh your local file system
and also gives you a file watching uh
capability so you can watch the files
when they change uh your function will
be called it will uh it should return
the contents uh that you want to be sent
to the client it will be sent to the
client uh the client is a chrome
extension um that will basically hot
swap the code and will
um
will get the new code in so you see it
automatically without refreshing the
browser
there are a few
drawbacks to it like for example
if you already have state on the page
that will
changing the code will not change the
state because the state already existed
so a lot of times you need to write
custom code in order to update your
state every time
the code changes
thank you
any questions
so for flow you have uh
pre-processor support
yeah right um so actually like anything
support so
so yeah so so uh
yeah there's a file watcher and every
time the file changes it will call a
function of your choosing and basically
pass you a call back it's like do
whatever you want this is the file that
changed uh just give me the back the
content and the static resource name and
i'll update the client with it all right
also follow up on that yeah how's that
for your battery life
flow
like watch
so so
uh
the state of watching files and node is
pretty broken
uh and there are a lot of tools and i
think a lot of people uh
talk about the better life because of
tools like gaze
and tools that do polling i think
choccydar just uses also includes
includes a native extension a lot of
those are really resource intensive but
i've written another one just to use it
for flow called sane
and and this actually this is an
interesting story um
from the ember team uh
why they switched to sane one one of
them were was on a flight and uh he was
running out of battery i think they were
using gaze and it was like eating up
better life and he switched to sane just
to save up battery uh in order to to
continue his his flight and and write
his code so yeah so check it out saying
npm package i'm really amazed that you
managed to boost the one working file
system watcher
i've been using cases i've not seen
these problems maybe because i've
tweaked my ultimate
i
where are these issues coming from
uh i don't know i i've seen it
definitely when i was using it just like
cpu just like uh the cpu
just
it hogs up the cpu for some reason okay
um i feel so not cool for never having
the problem of the battery life bound
yeah like while you're programming
something in an airplane
if i only have these better watches
this is the only use case by the way
all right
great thank you